- I'm Governor Bobby Jindal,
and I'm here to take on the
issues through push-ups.
- [Voiceover] Coming to you live
from the BuzzFeed
studios in the Big Apple,
we're just moments away from
putting politics to the push-up mat.
Governor Bobby Jindal, in the building,
ready to go.
Let's see who he's up against.
Taxes, his first foe.
The governor's not a fan,
but if you don't pay em,
you go to prison.
You can ask Wesley Snipes.
Obamacare coming off a huge win
at the Supreme Court earlier this year.
This battle is one to watch.
The governor has said countless times
that he's tired of hyphenated Americans.
Definitely no love lost here.
And of course, the
fiercest challenger today,
Governor Jindal's very own
2009 State of the Union response speech.
These two have history
and it's not pretty.
(ringing bell)
Let's go to the floor.
- Now we're talking a lot today
about 2009 State of the
Union response speech
cause it was a tough one.
Now do you think you're overlooking
Obamacare and taxes today?
- These are tough competitors.
The stronger the taxes get,
the less freedom we all have,
so you can't overlook
either one of these two.
- Wow, you heard that here first.
So we're going to get
right to the competition.
Are you ready?
Do you need anything
like some gym clothes?
- I'm good to go, let's go.
- We're good to go.
Let's put politics and
push-ups to the test.
(ringing bell)
- [Voiceover] Competitors
down on your mats.
Ready, get set, and go!
(cheers)
- [Voiceover] Taxes is down.
Not a strong showing, but
hey, we'll see you next April.
(heavy rock music)
- [Voiceover] And hyphenated
Americans hit the mat.
Looks like the governor was right.
We are all just Americans,
at least for today.
Obamacare is out. Incredible!
Absolutely shocking.
Governor Jindal rolling back
landmark legislation in under 30 push-ups.
Two long time rivals.
Mano a mano, neck and neck,
neither wants to give in.
Neither want to show any weakness.
What an effort from these two competitors.
With every push, a grudging
respect growing between them.
Incredible.
The State of the Union response
is pushing Jindal to keep going.
asking just one more
push-up from the governor.
Just one more.
And Oh! Jindal's knee is on the mat.
Jindal's knee is on the mat!
It's over! It's over!
(chanting U.S.A.)
- [Gov. Jindal] I think we can
finally put this behind us.
I think America won today.
(triumphant music)